and the man who wrote the book literally
figuratively on coach k and has been uh
covering uh tiger woods for many a moon
wrote a book about arnie and jack back
in his day as well from the new york
post author ian o'connor back here on
the rich eisen show how are you doing
ian
hey rich i have to follow marissa it's
homemade that's that's a tough action
yes you know what and nance too it went
nance and then that's right yes and then
we played an archival uh a video of uh
of marissa tome and now you you know
conor but we think you know the third
time is the charm let's put it that way
how does that sound sounds good okay
so how do you think what coach k is
handling the last 48 hours
72 hours
i think he's probably just trying to
figure out exactly what he's going to do
here he's been running teams an
assembling team since he was 12 years
old in chicago
so for 63 years later did not have a
team to
to try to fix to try to piece together
to recover from to lead yeah i i think
he's probably a little lost for one i
don't know how he felt about last
night's results
i it would seem to me that
if unc wins well at least we lost to the
to the championship team
uh but losing well now they felt the
pain that we had to feel twice once in
cameron and of course
in new orleans and and maybe you would
want that for your
chief rival i don't know
it's an interesting thing i think on
truth serum i'd like to hear his answer
to that question
but i think i think the overriding thing
is just not having a team anymore to
to lead is probably a really foreign
thing he's got to deal with right now
really for the rest of his life i asked
jay billis in the first hour if there
was any chance at all that the
speculation just and and there it's
totally unfounded there's doesn't seem
to be any smoke or fire at all just it's
just a bunch of people thinking that the
way it all finished up that he loses to
carolina and cameron for his final home
game on campus and then he loses to
carolina in the first ever meeting
between the two storied programs in the
final four that he just wouldn't be able
to walk away
you're laughing and billy said no way
and then he took a broadside at saying
that if he ever did it he should break
he should do it at a time most important
to tom brady because brady unretired
during this election sunday bracket show
that he was on espn so that was an
interesting answer from jay what do you
think you already laughed you already
laughed about it right well i i'm
actually surprised rich the amount of
people who've asked me that question
and since the loss of saturday i was in
the superdome before heading over here
to to augusta national
and i at age 75 you just can't come back
from that and i have to say this and
just i sat right across from hubert
davis in that game
and he was so intensely engaged in every
single possession and the refs kept
warning him to back it down
and i mean he did not take one
possession off and i remember covering
him with the knicks and he was not
really that kind of persona
and so i was a little surprised at that
and then i looked across the floor at
coach k
who was really sitting on his stool for
for most of that game
and i have to say being honest that
there aids different step that was in my
mind
and and so
i i just there is no way i don't think
the school could really even let him
come back after the farewell tour it's
like there's just no way
that could even be a possibility even if
he wanted to i believe the school would
say absolutely not
you know we can't we can't
just release what we just went through
for a year no i i don't think that would
be allowed frankly it's his court ian
he's his name's on the court you know
what i mean yeah right but i mean listen
he had to constantly field questions
about the pre-announcement announcing
the announcement in advance and a lot of
people were critical that they go
through this for a year
i i just don't think the university
could run that back
i think there's just no way tom brady
coming back i i would have been shocked
if he didn't come back
um based on a one-pass conversation i
have with him for one but just he he was
one of the best players in the nfl at
age 44. so why wouldn't you come back
but
yeah not after a victory tour you you
can't you there's just no coming back
from that so i i never thought that was
there was any possibility of that
happening coach k the author of the book
coach k mike shachet the uh
the uh um the rise and reign of mike
szyszewski author you know conor here on
the rich eisen show and just like jim
nance uh you went from new orleans to
augusta um so uh i i can't believe it
man and and and i've learned you know
when it comes to tiger or jordan right
those are the two guys that just leave
to mind kobe may he rest in peace
you can't put anything past him but
i mean really 14 months after
almost losing your leg in a car accident
and here he is saying i think i can win
the masters and i have to believe him
because he's tiger woods and
he believes it i i can't i i can't even
put in perspective ian i'll i'll leave
it up to you to try and do that
well that was that was the very column i
just sent into my office about an hour
ago
that if tiger wood says it you have to
if he believes it then i think you need
to believe it too
now ben hogan did win the u.s open
after nearly being killed by a greyhound
bus 16 months after that this is tiger
now what less than 14 months it'll be
to try to pull this off
and circumstances were a little
different of course
but his right leg was almost amputated
and here he is now in december you
recall when he played with his son
charlie and the father-son the pnc
as far as hitting the ball he looked
good he's hitting 350 yard drives and it
was the walking of course and still the
case today that's the problem
but unlike some of the other great
athletes you referenced and others his
sport doesn't require him to run
his his sport just requires him to
to walk from one moment to the next and
he delivers his greatness in a
stationary position standing still
and so he's allowed to he has the
opportunity to pull this off do i think
he can win sunday yes
i'm sorry if tiger woods believes it
then i think after i was there in 2019 i
didn't really i had a hard time
believing that he could do that
but but after pulling that off and
winning 82 times and and listen and 14
years ago
he won the u.s open and played 91 holes
in the u.s open and won on one leg his
other leg his left leg had an acl tear
and two stress fractures in it
so
yes
can he win sunday i absolutely believe
he can well i mean jim dance again with
whom we just hung up ian o'connor said
that he sat down with tiger for a
special that's airing uh on sunday on
cbs an hour before their
the last day's broadcast uh he sat down
with him about a month ago
had no indication that this was possible
and that their their their interview
time got pushed a little bit because
tiger was in the middle of a workout he
said lasted four hours
and i i cannot imagine do you ever do we
have any details as to
what he's done i mean again this man had
open fractures
of his tibia fibula i mean his
his foot was crushed i mean do we have
any concept of what his regimen has been
to get to this point
uh the specifics he's not gotten into
now it's it's clear that he can't
and i've talked to people close to him
he can't he used to get to the course so
early like for instance yesterday i was
on the first tee box at like 6 59 a.m
before it was still dark because the old
tiger he'd get out there
as early as possible to get his work in
and i thought there was a chance he
might do that well he didn't end up
teeing off until 2 45 in the afternoon
somebody close to him said to me you
know tiger with these injuries it it
takes him a while to get his day started
he needs
a lot of prep work
and rehab and physical therapy in the
morning to get that motor going
and so
i think it's been obviously very
extensive he said the surgeons gave him
an opportunity and now he has to endure
the pain to sort of seize that
opportunity to win this tournament
and it's interesting to me that his tea
time thursday i knew they would they
would give him early thursday late
friday to give him the best chance to
recover from thursday it reminds me of
that jimmy connors run at the u.s open
when he was what 38 39 years old and
they kept giving him night matches give
him the best chance
but i think at 10 what he's seeing off
at 10 34 on thursday that gives him an
opportunity to have a few hours in the
morning to just be able to be ready for
that and i don't know if that factored
into the master's tee time decision
there but
uh he's obviously gone through hell to
to get to this point to me and i
remember in november december when he we
saw him publicly he he looked physically
bigger up top so i think he did a lot of
upper body work
and
yeah his strength is off the charts in
his upper body and and so now it's just
a question of walking fred couples said
yesterday he looks phenomenal the way
he's hitting the ball it's as good as
basically anybody justin thomas included
it's just can he walk 72 holes on one
good leg like he walked 91 holes on one
good leg 14 years ago to win the us open
but the bottom line is if anybody can do
it it's this guy
right i mean that's just that's it
i can't believe it i can't believe the
25th anniversary of his of his first win
there too uh uh they must be over the
moon
uh espn cbs
the the the folks at augusta national
they must be out of their minds over the
moon that this has happened
you know right uh cbs didn't get coach k
in the national championship game
uh they get tiger woods uh sunday on the
back nine with a chance to win i again i
was here in 2019 i've been doing this
for 36 37 years that's the best sporting
event i've ever covered right
and if he wins this that'll make i think
i wrote my column 2019 feel as small as
a range ball i mean
this would be just ridiculously
unbelievable but because tiger woods
says it can happen just like michael
jordan or serena williams or tom brady
they have so much credibility if they
say it can happen then i have to believe
it too i'm glad you mentioned serena i
should have mentioned her before that
she's exactly perfect it's a perfect
person to mention
i mean phelps right i mean that that
that that's who we're talking about here
that's the level we're talking about
here and i i'm i'm jealous and uh
appreciative uh of uh of you and and for
you to to to join here ian so uh from my
colleague to my right um who's a duke
met fan um you know he's still feeling
it the pain tj jefferson uh
can you tell tj who's starting for the
mets who's the opening day starter for
the mets right now is it you or is it me
who is it where is it ian what do you
got for me yeah i don't know
i i live my wife of uh many years is
died and died with the mets we watch
every game at home and she can't believe
the grime is hurt again and now
scherzer's
status and
yeah it's uh tough she's very happy that
buck showalter is the manager of the
mets she should be i love that guy i
thought by the way great hire i think
he's perfect i think he's terrific
honestly listen he
buck thought he was going to win the
world series in new york in in 94 and
and the world series was taken away from
him and everybody else but he thought so
this is another chance for him to win in
new york i do think he wouldn't admit
this publicly but i do think that joe
torre taking over and winning
all those championships with his yankees
team
uh that that hurt so he here's it here's
an opportunity for buck to uh deliver in
new york i think he will
uh but yeah it's it's unbelievable that
the mets only the mets it seems has uh
this this run of of bad luck and degrom
uh let's hope he's back sooner rather
than later yeah uh thanks for the call
you know connor uh enjoy it we'll chat
down the line but uh have a great time
in augusta have a great day thanks rich
you guys that's ian o'connor joining us
here on the rich eisen show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here